compris après 37 jours de guerre pas ou
peu d'espoir pour l'heure l'aviation
russe continue de bombarder sans relâche
et sans aucune distinction art actifs
les stations de métro sont le seul
refuge pour des milliers de civils on
retrouve tout de suite en direct depuis
cette ville du nord-est du pays notre
envoyé spécial roméo langlois bonjour à
vous romeo vous êtes avec catherine
moret sprinter et ashraf eux habite sur
place
roméo vous êtes justement dans une
station métro ce sont des abris de
fortune des abris improvisés pour des
milliers de civils depuis le début de
cette guerre
oui absolument je me trouve dans le nord
de la ville à la station de métro qui
s'appelle héros du travail et qui compte
actuellement 700 personnes qui une nuit
de plus s'apprêtent à dormir dans le
métro puisque encore une fois
aujourd'hui dans ce secteur qui est l'un
des plus violemment pilonnée par
l'artillerie russe de toute la ville de
kharkiv est bien il ya eu des explosions
encore toute la journée donc ici dia 700
personnes c'est probablement l'une des
mêmes certainement la plus l'une des
plus peuplées de toutes les stations du
métro d kharkiv étant donné que c'est
l'une des zones les plus dangereuses
alors la plupart de ces personnes sont
des personnes âgées des personnes âgées
comme par exemple li na qui à près de 80
ans qui l'expliquent elle est venue
évidemment pour fuir les bombardements
voilà maintenant cinq semaines qu'elle
n'est quasiment jamais
elle a trop peur d'aller à l'extérieur
et ensuite elle ne veut pas elle ne veut
pas sortir et là elle pense que
ses jambes ne lui permettent pas de
sortir l'état son état de santé il ya
aussi de nombreux enfants qui sont à
l'intérieur d'après à une volontaire
avec qui j'ai parlé une bénévole il ya
cinquante et un enfants qui sont à
l'intérieur et qui sont toujours malades
d'après ces volontaires et qui j'ai
parlé et il ya aussi des familles des
familles entières qui se réfugient dans
le métro par exemple la famille de serdy
cergy qui était qui et physicien
chercheur en physique nucléaire et dans
l'université a été bombardé je pensais
j'ai rencontré aussi à une jeune femme
de 18 ans qui s'appelle anastasia elle
est traductrice elle expliqué elle ce
qui les met dans la vie eh bien c'était
sortir faire la fête avec ses copains et
espérer devenir traductrice voyager de
par le monde elle se retrouve depuis
cinq semaines une fois de plus à passer
ses journées à l'intérieur du métro est
me racontait détails touchant qu'elle a
qu'elle possède une perruche bleu et
jaune aux couleurs de l'ukraine et que
régulièrement quand les bombardements se
calme elle sort de chez elle sans du
métro pour se rendre dans son
appartement afin de nourrir sa sa
perruche alors les conditions sanitaires
de l'imaginer sont très difficiles il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de douche il
y à des sanitaires qui sont dont je vous
laisse imaginer l'état donc le pour se
doucher les personnes soit sorte et à
rentrer chez elle quelques temps ou
alors elle se douchent le pratiquent des
douches de chat on va dire à l'intérieur
des sanitaires ce qui est impressionnant
c'est le niveau de solidarité que l'on
peut trouver à l'intérieur de ce metroid
à une vingtaine de bénévoles qui sont la
permanence de manière permanente et des
dizaines d'autres qui viennent tous les
jours dernier point vous avez pu le voir
personne ne possède de masse qui si je
demandais justement à lui deux bémols
pourquoi certains craignent le corona
des prix et elle disait qu'elle
craignait beaucoup plus les bombes russe